Human Rights Watch says meta has
silenced posts in support of Palestine
on Instagram and Facebook it says the
supression the suppression rather is
systemic and Global amounting to what
seems to be the largest wave of
censorship of content about Palestine to
date the Rights group reviewed 1,50
cases of online censorship from more
than 60 countries they were largely in
English nearly all of them featured
peaceful content in support of Palestine
the organization says that in more than
300 cases users were unable to appeal
meta's removal of content or accounts
effectively it's identified six patterns
of censorship content removal suspension
or permanent disabling of accounts and
restrictions on liking commenting
sharing or reposting it's also found
restrictions on tagging or following
other accounts limited use of certain
meta features and Shadow Banning uses
that means significant drop in the
visibility of a user's posts stories and
account well Nadin miladi joins us now
from Doha he's professor of media and
Communications at katar University thank
you very much for joining us um so what
do you make of this there have long been
allegations and uh and you know
complaints about this kind of behavior
from meta um what do you make of this
latest piece piece of
research well I think this is the
culmination of a systematic pressure
um from around the world especially
policy makers in the west and in
addition to the Israeli government on
social media platforms like meta and x
and others unfortunately meta has been
uh in the last um few months and and
especially after 2021 the Sheikh sharah
events in Jerusalem has been um kind of
um um placing a very very obvious um
systematic way of controlling and
monitoring anything related to Palestine
anything related to Palestinian content
and what we've been uh kind of um uh
listening or hearing from activists or
from academics or from um um social
media uh organizations uh around the
world about meta censoring their content
and I think now we've seen it uh
documented by Human Rights Watch and
unfortunately this is another uh kind of
way of caving in to the pressure from
the Israeli government specifically this
is dangerous this is um
unprecedented uh to to to to to for meta
to kind of come to this uh way of
controlling content and this definitely
will affect the image not only of meta
but also other social media platforms
where Palestinian content is controlled
where um uh free speech is actually
monitored and also censored so this this
sends really a big alarm this sends
reverberation in my opinion from around
the world and I hope meta will take
initiatives in the future to do some
justice to the Palestinian content to do
some justice to the Palestinian people
who every day now we've been seeing the
atrocities the bombardment of their land
of the of the instructure infrastructure
in Gaza and uh in in uh um uh the West
Bank in other parts of um Palestine uh
so um let's hope that this is this will
not this will be a phase and let's hope
that we come to normality
soon um and let's hope that the um uh uh
International pressure will mount on
social media Network because honestly
it's it's now thanks to social media
networks that the in addition to Al
jazer and some other International
channels that we are here hearing and
watching and witnessing the um the the
the the um atrocities in Gaza but um
otherwise probably all of those um
atrocities would have been uncovered
would have been without a witness you
mentioned uh the issue of shik CH in
2021 and the uh similar story
surrounding the attempted Force removal
of Palestinians from their homes in
occupied East Jerusalem there I I was
reporting from Jerusalem at the time and
I remember isra activists were talking
about posts inciting violence or
supporting Hamas and and defending these
sorts of bans on those grounds but
what's interesting about this research
whatever you you make of those
allegations at that time Human Rights
Watch has said that
1,049 of these instances of the 1,50
that it considered they were all
peaceful so it gives Facebook and
Instagram less room really to to argue
that that this is warranted
no absolutely but um uh this mean this
means that um um uh any Palestinian
content now whether it is peaceful or
not peaceful in a way uh is considered
by meta is considered by the Israeli
government is is considered by some of
the policy makers around the world
who've been putting pressure on meta
that it is um not allowed and this
probably will will by the way will
probably put pressure on other social
media networks to all Al probably in the
future like X for example to to to to to
take some some some some similar
measures this also probably will put
some pressure on other um let's say um
um newspapers or uh Global channels um
like television channels to also censor
Palestinian contact so this is really a
dangerous step and and I think and I
think human rights organizations like
Human Rights Watch Amnesty International
and many others I think they they are
doing the right thing and in my opinion
they should raise the alarm they should
talk about this um um measure as a
against Free Speech against the basic
human rights of um uh um revealing the
true accounts of the atrocities of the
genocide that is happening uh not only
in Gaza but in in all Palestinian land
on all Palestinian people including uh
Jerusalem what does this say about
content moderation more broadly because
obviously Twitter now X has seen its
content moderating ability hugely you
know hollowed out since the Takeover by
Elon Musk and people have in some ways
been praising the fact that meta and
others do still have content moderators
who are trying to police what's going on
but it does uh on the one hand you have
almost a wild west of anything going and
on the other hand you have uh the issue
of who really judges what is appropriate
and what isn't I mean it's it's a bit of
a Minefield for these companies to pick
their way
through no I'm I'm sure it is
problematic definitely if I am a person
for example who is in the um um control
room of of meta or um X probably I will
I will I will be facing huge pressure
from both sides from for example Israeli
lobbies who are try trying to censor
every form of Palestinian content and
also from the rest of the world um who
is supportive of the Palestinian
narrative to um uh to to to to to to Pro
provide a free speech platform uh so so
so certainly if I am one of those in the
in in that position I would be facing a
lot of pressure but certainly I mean I
would also be fair in terms of
moderating the the content yes we we we
do refute every form of content that
proposes um uh condoning terrorism or
what have you but at the same time I
mean what you've just mentioned is a
peaceful content about Palestine about
demonstrations about showing support to
the Palestinian narrative itself without
necessarily showing support for example
to Hamas or any other uh military group
so this is where the concern is really
so I I I think the bottom line in my
opinion which meta and all the social
media platforms should take into
consideration is um uh supporting the
basic human rights of Palestinians is
not wrong uh and it shouldn't be
considered as anti- Zionist and it
shouldn't be considered as anti-jew or
anti-israeli this is a basic human
rights that should be uh condone that's
basic human right that should be
preserved in a way and um uh any other
form of of let's say suggesting um
anti-jewish sentiment obviously should
be should be censored any any any other
form of suggesting um causing Havoc
between ethn ethnicities and communities
should be also censored but here we are
talking about the basic free human uh
free rights of uh supporting what is
happening to the Palestinians in Gaza in
West Bank in Jerusalem in all other
parts of Palestine I mean we see it now
every day Palestinians are putting cages
in Jerusalem Palestinians are putting
cages in West Bank Palestinians are
putting cages in in in in in Gaza their
lives is exterminated their humanity is
exterminated so if I talking to you
about these atrocities um I should be
allowed this platform on every form of
legal
um kind of social social media Network
nin Madi from Doha from Kata University
thank you very much for
analysis thank you for inviting me